russia's president is talking about the
military standoff in ukraine for the
first time in more than a month vladimir
putin accused the u.s and its allies
yesterday of ignoring russia's concerns
that ukraine may join nato the western
military alliance putin has deployed at
least 100 000 troops around ukraine the
u.s has now sent fighter jets and
support units to estonia the nato ally
that used to be part of the soviet union
charlie dagda is in tolene that's
estonia's capital with more on this
story charlie good morning to you
good morning to you gail subfreezing
temperatures are a far cry from north
carolina where this squadron is based
around 120 u.s military personnel taking
part in this mission right on russia's
doorstep
american f-15 screaming eagles soar into
darkening skies
in a show of u.s military firepower
the message to nato allies here we've
got your back and to russia we're
watching the us air force's 336 fighter
squadron taking part in an enhanced air
policing mission and it's it's about
reassuring your nato allies
yeah absolutely this is a a team effort
from the nato alliance here's why it
matters the baltic states are sandwiched
between russia and its ally belarus and
the baltic sea the russian military's
already deployed fighter jets to the
region launched naval exercises in the
baltic sea and rolled missile systems
into belarus
this mission was created in a direct
response to russian military aggression
and now with moscow threatening once
more it's never been more vital to the
security of this region
bolstering the baltics with additional
american forces began after the
russian-backed incursion of eastern
ukraine and the annexation of crimea in
2014.
the head of the estonian air force told
us those u.s jets are crucial yeah the
bolster to strengthen the air policing
at the show primarily to show that the
alliance is taking its business
seriously
now the brigadier general told us that a
russian fighter did cross into nato
airspace just over the weekend leaders
here are calling for more u.s support
the prime minister saying the biggest
deterrence to russia is an american flag
tony
charlie dagetta for us in estonia
charlie thank you very much